Flash start Paul Pelosi the only guy
that knows how I felt all right
just me and you Paul
just me and you babe
[Applause]
all right so I met Sandler here's a
weird thing
I went to school in the 70s I was a 1972
I was bus to school right and I was like
the only black kid in my school I was
only me and two other black girls it was
just us in uh Brooklyn and uh you know
it was it wasn't Selma
but
wasn't Selma but it was like Boston
same basket right
now how many times do you think a kid
asked me to hang out at his house
once
once in like 16 years David Moskowitz
the Jews nice people
nice people
so I
met sailor at the comic strip here's the
thing about the comic strip I I started
before Sandler and it takes about two
years to get a weekend spot
you know so I used to like you know
stack chairs and mop floors and and I do
my little spots and at very late and it
took forever it took me two years to get
a weekend spot at
comic strip
one year
I'm gone for about 10 days Eddie Murphy
saw me at the club flew me to La I'm
gone for two weeks right I come back on
a Saturday night and who do I see on
stage
Adam Sandler I'd never seen him before
in my life and we're like kind of the
same age and he's on on a weekend and
I'm like hold up what is this guy
that he gets a weekend spot so fast
right so I was supposed to hate him
and I'm watching them and he does this
joke about uh Wilt Chamberlain Wilt
Chamberlain once scored a hundred points
in the game and Sandler does this joke
and goes uh here's my impression of the
coach of the other team
who's God will
so I've watched this like the funniest
joke in the world I'm like I'm laughing
so hard and I was like God damn it this
guy's good
and right away all that jealousy and
hate and whatever it just like washed
away
it's just like okay and he comes off
stage we meet this first time we met
then he watches my set and I did okay
and then the greatest thing in the world
to the guy who no one wanted to play
with Adam goes hey we're going over to
my dorm you want to hang
and he's been letting me hang ever since
and I love the guy because he you know
Jews
you gotta love it
that's my guy
that's that has been my I've known this
guy for 30 years
and you know uh your kids are here
the Oscars are you know they're
and
if they don't want to give my man up his
props we will tonight ladies and
gentlemen one of the greatest of all
time